oh this is why when this when these new
when new blood comes in they're gonna
start changing up the game a little bit
which it has to happen soon because a
few years back I was also working with
this company and it was a on a TV show
that I was gonna sell but there was a
person who got replaced in this come and
I hated this person so [ __ ] much
because it was somebody who I know for a
fact because I've seen it so many times
this person didn't do anything and they
got paid so much money but so for
example this is how arbitrary this
[ __ ] human being is and you know I'm
not I'm not an employee of that company
so you can't pull this [ __ ] on me
and when I tell you that I'm not
confrontational but I will call out
[ __ ] when bullsh is being put on me
because you're wasting my [ __ ] time
yeah that shit's crazy it pisses me off
so for example it would be some [ __ ]
like this he goes hey David let's uh
let's let's hop on this conference call
real quick I need to well we could we
could set up a tie-in at 8 a.m. in the
morning and we could get on this
conference call I know and I went right
back on the email I was like wasting my
time it's like well it can it be done
through email or do we need to have a
conversation about this on conference
call because I'm busy so if you could
just write to me what your pitch is on
email then let me let me think about it
and then let's hop on a colleague goes
no man we gotta do it in person
cool calls me up right he goes hey bro
so this is the idea do you like it I'm
like yeah it's cool like cool man we'll
talk about with our team I'll hit you
back up and I was like hold on a second
I explicitly wrote to you on the email
if you could just write it to me why did
you why did I have to wake up at 8 a.m.
in the [ __ ] morning to have you asked
me a question who could have done that
you know right yeah because oh I just
need to get that verbal confirmation and
I'm like bro this and I didn't say this
to him but it's him pretending to work
so his boss thinks that he's working
yeah that's why he's doing the
conference call because he puts it in
his schedule that his boss sees well did
you just wake me up after I after I just
been editing a video till 5 [ __ ] a.m.
to bring me up on a conference call to
ask me a [ __ ] question for five
seconds yeah and then you know I got so
annoyed to the point where we were
having these group calls about this show
idea and then we were trying to develop
it and then eventually this guy got
fired by the way the new like CEO came
in and they did evaluations on people
who saw how lazy he was yeah so this guy
I got so [ __ ]
pissed I remember I was on the phone
calm there was a couple other people
around me and bigoted ni was irritated
this guy because we'd wrote an email and
then he sent me this schedule and he was
basically it was supposed to be an excel
sheet yeah and in this excel sheet I
said hey he goes I was like hey if you
guys want to work out ideas that you're
trying to pitch me on can you go let's
let's work out these these things that
we need on an excel sheet and then we
can fill it in together and then we can
work in that way because you guys I'm
based in LA you guys are based across
across country so let's figure it out
like that he goes - I'll send you an
excel sheet full sends me an excel sheet
it just says an excel sheet that says
ideas on it it was a mine was a [ __ ]
Google Doc that said ideas on it that's
it that's just a doc that says ideas and
I got so [ __ ] mad did he capitalize
the eye at least it was bolded and then
I wrote back lol I was like when you
send me something real let me know it
was - the whole team yeah it calls me
him he goes ain't like I'm just been
super [ __ ] busy like I know I was
like I could I know how to do an excel
sheet I just wanted to get it out there
so we could just have to start jotting
down is D and I remember on the phone I
was like amen
to do a proper excel sheet it takes
about five to six minutes yeah at most
just say you don't know how to do a man
yeah just say you don't know how to use
Excel like that I was like bro I have to
roast you on that [ __ ] because that's
hilarious
yeah because I got he's like all right
man like I'll I'll send you something
better send me another one
trash as I [ __ ] so I got merry old to
do one cuz I know she's a coordinator
sending one I was like this is what I'm
expecting right sent it out you know
kind of embarrassed him in front of a
few people yeah so I don't know he
doesn't like me and then later on he
does something yeah he pulls another
[ __ ] stunt more on the excel sheet I
wrote a bunch of [ __ ] ideas right and
then while he's doing this in a group
chat with a bunch of people who are
under him and some people were above him
all the ideas that I wrote on the excel
sheet he goes he goes hey so I got this
great idea right and he starts prattling
all these ideas that were my ideas that
excel sheet and in the conference call I
remember I said that's cause like so
cool so you read it so you're basically
reading out loud what I wrote yeah he's
like dead silent so he's calling how
what I mean he didn't think that you
would realize I was like so this is why
I said verbatim looks like so you're
basically reading everything I wrote did
you read my email yeah well are you just
saying this off the top of your head cuz
I wrote this in the email
right lazy [ __ ] dead silent yeah I
think he goes Otto he's like these are
ideas that was think I was like no these
aren't your ideas yeah I was like in
everything do you guys have a computer
can you open up the excel sheet yeah
it's right there I wrote all these ideas
so you're not saying anything new I
would slap his [ __ ] face do you know
and then he's like stumbling over his
lords right and he clangs after the
conference calls he hangs up after he
goes in my bad man I didn't know those
were your ideas I was thinking the same
thing and I was like bro you weren't
thinking the same thing man
if you read the lying sack of [ __ ] house
like if you read the [ __ ] email you
know what's in there man
like come on cut that [ __ ] out I want to
I want to be in your situations just
like I could talk [ __ ] to people yeah
it's you know what it's it's pretty
refreshing too because like the
conference call version of what I said
to him after the conference call was a
lot nicer because I'm not trying to
[ __ ] get him fired but I would but
but afterwards I'm a little irritated
cuz you can't take credit for my [ __ ]
work yeah you know what I mean yeah so
it was like that's what I don't like
about the corporate world sometimes
everybody is just out for their own ass
and they will make sure that you would
drown if it keeps their head afloat hate
that this is a toxic work culture dude
I've gotten guys fired at my companies
yeah it's a hotel my I would I would I
would work with my manager I'll be like
hey that guy's [ __ ] lazy yeah and I'm
like why do you keep him around and he
goes aw you don't understand Joe he has
two kids and I'm like but doesn't that
make doesn't doesn't it make sense if he
has two kids he should work [ __ ]
harder it not not be a complaining
entitled little [ __ ] like why does he
get special treatment because you feel
sorry for him and he's like I know
you're right man but it's different like
you know when you have a family I'm like
nah dude III don't respect this guy and
I'm like I was like why don't we move
them to a different department and I
promise you I'll take over his work
without extra money so he's like really
you'll do that and I'm all like yeah
he's bottlenecking us so [ __ ] hard
that it's irritating me and I'll take
over his work and I can do it I know I
can because the thing is that who he's
one of those guys that he he tricks the
system and I hate people like this and
they'll dumb milk they'll milk the
[ __ ] thing always pretend injury back
pain all this [ __ ]
my manager is a [ __ ] sweetheart he
loves and cares for his employee to the
point where he's not smart about it he
gets taken advantage of and so I saw
this [ __ ] lazy [ __ ] doing this and
then and then always like I would see it
right after lunch he wants to [ __ ]
relax more so he's like oh man you know
like like I can I take a little extra
break cuz you know like I'm lifting
these boxes and I'm like every [ __ ]
time like clockwork
after [ __ ] lunch this guy wants to
take another 30-minute break
lazy [ __ ] while all of us work because
right after lunch we hustle hard so we
could finish early right yeah and then
I'm like I'm just wit I'm just seeing
all these like tricky little things this
[ __ ] does and I was like well if you
don't have the heart to fire him let's
just move them to a different department
and then we got him to a different
Department I took over his work and then
I was like bro
I could [ __ ] finish mine and his work
easily before lunch yeah and I'm like he
wasn't even doing [ __ ] dude he's
pretending to work taking money away he
was he was working on an assembly line
packing [ __ ] like he milked his orders
he had about eight orders and he took
him from like 9:00 in the morning all
the way till 2:00 p.m.
yeah to do in these eight orders I could
fall I'll [ __ ] fill at like 11:00
a.m. yeah so it's like things like that
drive me crazy because I don't know man
I think for me I like working with the
team that gets together and we're
honorable and we [ __ ] fight hard Yeah
right and that's the type of people I
want to be around I don't want to be
around people who are [ __ ] snaky
liars cowards to me like they are the
[ __ ] of the earth so like in that
example like I would have called them
out right in front of everybody I'm like
you [ __ ] lied yeah why did you lie or
like um just recently there was this
whole fiasco I went through and I was
talking to these guys these old [ __ ]
white guys right and they try to
Hollywood me I hate when people try to
[ __ ] big dick Hollywood me and then
they'll be talking about like all the
money that's on the line and all these
stats to makes me go oh my god no I
literally in the middle of their talk I
said look I don't care like I cut
I was like I don't care you got a lot on
the line that's fine you know what let
me just [ __ ] you know I was just like
you got a lot on the line that's fine
whatever
good for you good good good like I was
patronizing as a [ __ ] cuz I
don't talk like that
yeah and I was just in and I was like
moving forward I was like this is my
point and I'm like you got till 2:00 you
gonna call me back before that if you
can't I'm not talking to you because I
have the rest of the day [ __ ] busy
alright bye yeah I just hang up on them